hello and welcome to the new world of
your source for everything anime and
manga and today we are here to talk
about a certain spiky head sort of
protagonist whose name and current
status in the hunter hunter series are
synonymous that being gone hunter hunter
is very bold series in many respects but
one of the factors that does lead it to
standing on its own unique plateau is
yoshihiro togashi making the decision to
retire his primary protagonist and
continue the main story with a new
protagonist karapika and his delightful
golden locks will be the face of hunt
hunter for the foreseeable future but
the recurring question on everyone's
minds is always going to be will gone
return and we are going to answer it but
it's all going to begin with a quick
round of going going gone a very simple
mini-game the rules of which are as
follows you have found yourself in a
hunter hunter auction featuring the
following three gone statues now one of
these is in fact the real gone and it's
going to be our job to guess which one
it is now should you guess incorrectly
then your punishment will be to
subscribe to the new world review thus
resulting in consistent injections of
hunter-based culture administered
directly into your youtube feed and if
you do guess correctly then you will be
forced to pay for the other two statues
and they are very expensive so it's
quite a high-stakes game here today so
which one is the real gone make your
choice now and we shall reveal the
answer in three two one and bam it was
gone a so if you guessed incorrectly
then you know the thing to do and please
do say hi in the comments below if you
are a recent inductee of our association
welcome with this whole gone returning
discussion though there's a number of
key questions that we will need to
answer we can't just do the standard
internet thing of oh i think gone should
come back because i like gone he punches
things good because unfortunately gone
needs reasons to come back reasons
plural and these reasons range from his
very own character drive to technical
aspects like regaining men and even
meta-story aspects like well what is
there left for gone to do and can
togashi even be bothered to write for
him anymore all of these are incredibly
important and for the sake of ease we're
going to start off with in-world
concerns character drive is our first
topic and it's actually one of the most
difficult to address if we're trying to
construct an argument for god's return
whilst tanta hunter is an undeniably
unique shonen series gone is a fairly
standard shonen protagonist even if he
does get a bit twisted and wrong towards
the end gone's drive and motivation
throughout the series mostly boils down
to finding his father jing that's why he
became a hunter in the first place to
hunt down his hunter father gon is a
hunter hunter if you will and during the
chairman election arc he finally
succeeded no it wasn't the epic glorious
final adventure thing that one might
have expected from a story in fact it
essentially boiled down to cornering his
father in hunter congress and having the
entire hunter association apply peer
pressure for jing to spend time with his
son it's underwhelming but gone still
did it he accomplished his goal as well
as his various side quests you know he
got closure with kite and kilowatt was
more or less freed of the zelda grasp so
if we're going to step back into the
story he would either have to want or
need something and to be fair it's not
too difficult to construct this kind of
scenario despite his dark turn gone is
the kind of kid who will very willingly
step into action if any of his friend
peeps happen to be in trouble even
though he does just generally cause them
more trouble but here's the thing even
if that situation was to pop up would
gon be capable of doing it so this
brings us back to nine hunter exam
archer side it's night on impossible to
exist in this story without some form of
nenus the enemies are becoming far too
powerful and the landscapes far too
brutal other than perhaps a couple of
sparse chapters here and there i can't
see gone returning in any kind of
functional capacity without the use of
nen and there is a point of contention
within the hunt hunt fanbase regarding
whether or not it's actually physically
possible for gon to become an ore user
again it's tricky because during his
transformation pito stated that he was
born with a gift and was willing to
throw that gift away he sacrificed all
of his men to do it he'll never be able
to use nen again just a nice little
rhyme then again then again again again
however this does seem pretty clear
however the very existence of nanika
throws everything into question because
it's incredibly vague as to exactly what
nanaka did to gon and this is because
killua's wish only consisted of a mere
simple two words those words being heal
gone it very much drives you into the
argument of can an infinitely powerful
person lift an equally as infinitely
heavy stone gone made a nen val forever
severing his connection with aura but
can nanika break that and furthermore
was that even a part of the wish to
begin with because the idea of healing
gone could very much be taken as
restoring his physical condition without
interfering with the nen val now this
doesn't mean that gon doesn't have any
aura any more because aura is more or
less required to live and jing did
confirm that he could see and or feel
gonzora but the gon probably just
couldn't see it himself anymore and
here's a very intriguing part a lot of
the people who argue that yes it is
possible for gone to regain his aura of
control will cite a conversation in
chapter 345 where gon was talking to
jing on the phone and that's because
there's a famous mistranslation in the
manga scans for this chapter where jing
allegedly states that gon reverted back
to normal and if he wanted more than
that then there would be a price to pay
and that is a pretty massive statement
to make because it would be jin
confirming that gon could more than
likely make another vow to access net
again albeit at a fairly great cost
however the official translation makes
no such implication and jing actually
states you turned back to normal you'd
be ungrateful if you wanted more which
implies the exact opposite as the scan
translation here jing is not speculating
over nenu's and he's actively
encouraging gon to count himself lucky
and start thinking about his postmen
life which is why it is important to
read the official translation for
discussions like this however it is
unfortunately not very easily or even
very cost effectively accessible to most
but for the sake of moving forward let's
say that hunter hunter is a fictional
story and the author can do whatever he
wants which includes going back on story
beats that he had previously implemented
good okay cool so with that meta
reasoning for what purpose would togashi
reintroduce gon and the first point of
interest that usually gets brought up is
of course hisoka one of the early key
hunt on to plot threads was gone's
rivalry with hisoka and it was a
definite rivalry in fact after their
match in heaven's arena gone vowed to
learn more about nen and find an ability
that would one day rival hisoka's bungee
gum so the argument can be made that god
actually needs to return in order to
close out this plot thread and if hunter
hunter were literally any other series
then i would agree the problem is it's
not it's it's hunter hunter and by very
nature just setting up a seemingly
integral piece of plot does not mean
that it will ever pay off and i know it
seems completely counter-intuitive to us
because stories well they're just not
supposed to do that they're supposed to
follow a very simple formula being set
up and payoff we as viewers invest time
so we expect a return on that investment
but that's also what makes hunter hunter
ever so special because sometimes
togashi will take the time to provide a
setup with no payoff or even try to
provide a payoff with no setup it
depends almost exclusively on how he's
feeling at any given time and this
battle at heaven's arena with hisoka was
published in 1999
more than 20 years ago and if you look
at how hunt hunters evolved over series
across those two decades i'd find it
very very hard to believe that togashi
is still gunning towards his old ideas
of the 90s untanta began as a fairly
standard shonen series and gradually
morphed into almost an anti-shonen
series breaking almost all of the
standard practices of the genre and
really giving tagashi an outlet to
express his dissatisfaction with those
practices which he was forced to adhere
to in his previous series yu hakusho the
series that famously burned him out and
honestly changed him forever and it is a
very standard shonen thing for the main
character to have a key antagonistic
rival this was set up for gone in the
hunter exam but just like the series
that rivalry dissipated over time as
gone and hisoka went their separate ways
so would i like to see a final clash
between gon and hisoka absolutely yes i
would sign me up but would i expect it
to happen just because togashi set it up
to happen 22 years ago absolutely not
both togashi and hunt hunter have
irrevocably changed since then and i
have no expectation that we are going to
return to those days if anything the
series is just going to continue to keep
evolving into new unknown forms that's
22 years ago though what about a plot
line that togashi set up a bit more
recently in the grand scheme of things
because after people have finished
discussing hisoka the next reason why
gone would seemingly return is his
unfinished or actually come to think of
it unstarted business with gyro so i
have a whole video on mr gyro which
explains his status and story
specifically to anime watches because
gyro in the manga is very very different
to his anime portrayal and there's some
pretty massive information that the
anime chooses to emit but the tldr is
that gyro is indeed alive and the
narrator of hunter hunter makes it very
painfully clear that he and gone will
have a key future connection gyro was
actually present in the same town as gon
and killua whilst they were training
with knuckle and the narrator go so far
as to state gyro left town and
disappeared without encountering gone
whether this proved to be fortunate for
either party will not be known until
they ultimately meet and i just like i
really don't know how much clearer an
author can be about setting up a future
story than that dogashi is effectively
saying you person with eyes you pay
attention to this because this is going
to be very relevant in the future and as
a result i find the gyro thread to be a
much stronger argument in favor of gone
returning than say the rivalry with
hisoka if only for the fact that whilst
the hisoka rivalry turned into a very
vague moosh of a relationship at the
very least at this stage togashi
obviously had a very clear idea about
where this whole gyro thing was going so
at least there was at that point in time
a guaranteed future for gone and once
again i need to emphasize that that was
the plan at the time not necessarily
anymore because that gyro chapter was
published in 2011 which is a bit too old
for my liking that's given togashi an
entire decade to ruminate develop new
interests and of course abandon old
ideas i mean just think about the person
you were 10 years ago these days you
probably have radically different
interests and goals in your own life and
whilst most long-running manga authors
do stick to their original premise
togashi is not constrained by his own
actions he's a bit of a badass that way
he just does whatever he wants whenever
he wants to do it regardless of whether
or not it makes sense or even outright
contradicts his own story which leaves
us with two meta questions the first of
which is can hunter hunter survive
without gone and i think the answer to
that is a definite yes right now in the
succession war there isn't a single gone
or even killer to be seen and yet it's
still an incredibly compelling
experience homes by karapika and
supported by many of the hunters we've
met to this point as well as the phantom
troop and of course all of the new
kharkian characters and when you think
about it even when gone was technically
the primary protagonist togashi had
slowly been retiring him for quite a
while the chimera antarc saw hunt hunt
become more of an ensemble series gone
didn't inhabit the role of main
character anymore and instead he became
part of an equally focused upon group
every member of the extermination team
held as much narrative weight as gon did
during the sark so hunter hunter has
long since been surviving without gone
necessarily at the forefront but the
other key and arguably more important
question is does togashi even want to
continue writing for gone because gone
kind of represents everything togashi
distastes about the shonen formula i
feel that gon is a very difficult
character for togashi to write because
his simple-minded nature doesn't always
gel with the story that togashi wants to
create that's why gone had to be subtly
pushed to the side for the orc nucidia
because his character wasn't suited to
writing a story about complex gang
warfare nor is it currently suited to a
royal killing game and arguably gone
also wasn't suited to an exploration
involving hyper-intelligent ants coming
to terms with humanity and the meaning
of their own existence that's why
togashi needed to radically change gon
from his simple optimistic archetype
into this super dark and psychologically
complex being which i suppose does go to
show that if togashi desires it yes he
can use gon but i don't think that he
wants to at least right now tagashi
seems much more invested in
investigating psychological battles
political intrigue and the deep
mysteries of the world and gone is far
from hunt hunter's strongest protagonist
to be used to implement that plus with
the idea that he has already completed
his series goal by finding his father
the fact that his non-ability is very
conveniently inaccessible and the idea
that togashi doesn't necessarily care
about his previously established plot
threads look with all of that in mind i
see very little reason to have hope for
gone returning in a primary role in the
future and that's not necessarily a bad
thing this kid has more than done his
time in that position so why not allow
him to retire to a normal life and a
happy ending on whale island and if
you'd like your own happy ending well
look we don't offer those here but i can
offer you more hunt hunter videos the
series may be on hiatus but we are
certainly not there is always more to
learn explore and experience so i look
forward to seeing you there